tensions are high in Israel and the West
Bank following three Palestinian attacks
on Israeli citizens over the past four
days yesterday an Israeli teenager was
stabbed and wounded in Jerusalem just
hours after a similar knife attack on
Saturday in which two men were killed
and a woman and her baby were injured
both attackers were shot dead by police
well the two fatal knife attacks in
Jerusalem followed the drive-by murder
of an Israeli couple he was shot dead in
their car in the West Bank last Thursday
they were killed in front of their four
children who were traveling with them
there have been clashes in East
Jerusalem and the West Bank between
Israeli police and Palestinians
following those latest attacks the
militant group Palestinian Islamic Jihad
has issued a statement claiming the
attacker in Saturday's fatal stabbings
was one of its members while we spoke to
the Middle East analyst Meir Javed amfAR
little earlier who's in Tel Aviv the
situation between Israelis and
Palestinians been escalating over the
past year we've seen a number of
terrorist attacks by Palestinians
against Israeli civilians Palestinian
terrorists using their cars to run over
his relatives we've seen increasing
number of stopping attacks lone wolf
attacks but at the same time also we've
seen that some extremist readies have
been targeting Palestinians so
unfortunately in this part of the world
instability and extremism seem to be on
the rise there is no hope there is no
hope on the Israeli side there is no
hope on the Palestinian side in Israel
more and more people believe that there
is no viable partner on the Palestinian
side and on the Palestinian side as a
settlement expansion continues as they
dispute Jewish access to you know the
al-aqsa mosque just people visiting
there there's rising hopelessness on
both sides and in the atmosphere of
desperation and hopelessness as we've
seen time and again in history and
especially in the Middle East the
extremists win and they seem to increase
their power a new
right now with same innocent
Palestinians in the West Bank innocent
Israelis in the West Bank innocent
Israelis in Jerusalem all over and in
Gaza in the West Bank inside Israel
proper people are increasingly becoming
targeted by extremists and this is a
serious cause for concern because our
region is already in unstable as it is
with Isis carrying out horrific killings
and assad on the other hand there's
already enough killings in this region
but unfortunately it seems israel
palestine is also becoming more and more
unstable with no prospect for
improvement in the near future there's
no doubt that Paris must be punished but
we must not pursue a policy that hurts
Israel that brings more instability and
more desperation and to this region and
to the Palestinians and and I think by
expanding settlements as a response and
by destroying the house of the families
of the terrorists we are only going to
help the extremists and we are going to
undermine our moral position inside
Israel in the international community
and of course do something that's really
not going to help stop future attacks
despite the sad and the dark mood I
think we must pursue peace not because
of any other reason other than is the
best way to fight terrorism and to give
people hope the people of Israel deserve
hope people of Palestine deserve hope
because if we lose hope the only people
who are going to win is going to be is
the minority extremists